the iconic point-and-click Adventure
series returns with a heartfelt and
nostalgic Adventure that any Mighty
pirate would be a fool to miss a
palpable fondness for the first two
Monkey Island games emanates throughout
every Three-Headed Monkey gag and bout
of insult sword fighting in return to
Monkey Island it's the kind of love that
trickles down from the top as guybrush
threepwood's latest Adventure sees
Creator Ron Gilbert welcome back into
the fold for the first time since 1991's
Monkey Island 2 the Chuck's Revenge the
self-described grumpy gamer helmed
development on this unexpected sequel
alongside veteran designer and writer
Dave Grossman and The Talented team at
developer terrible toy box with this in
mind it should come as no surprise that
return to Monkey Island is tinged with
Nostalgia and leans into this
wistfulness with obvious Joy it's also a
thrilling sequel in its own right one
that sees the Beloved series return in
swashbuckling fashion by incorporating
ideas both old and new
much like the earliest games in the
series return to Monkey Island is a
traditional 2D point-and-click Adventure
game built on storytelling and puzzle
solving hapless protagonist guybrush 3
foot is back older and only slightly
wiser this time around the Intrepid
pirate is also joined by plenty of
returning characters including his usual
cohort Elaine Marley and zombie arch
nemesis lechuk however the most
intriguing aspect of return to Monkey
Island is that it picks up right where
the Chuck's Revenge left off in
returning to the series Gilbert and
Grossman wanted to use this opportunity
to finally shed some light on that
game's Cliffhanger ending yet return to
Monkey Island isn't exactly a direct
sequel either for one it takes into
account the events of each Monkey Island
game released after 1991. with
characters like Murray the Demonic
talking skull making an appearance hey
Murray anything on the horizon only your
eventual ultimate obliteration how it
does this and the way it struck
structures its narrative framework is
fascinating but delving into specifics
would encroach on major spoiler
territory instead I'll just say this
unique approach adds a mysterious
wrinkle to an otherwise simple tale and
the ending is no less provocative than
the conclusion to lechuck's Revenge the
main thrust of the narrative revolves
around finally uncovering The Secret of
Monkey Island guybrush isn't in a
position to do so at the beginning of
the game being both shipless and
crewless so your first task is to find a
way off the familiar melee Island this
is easier said than done and it doesn't
take long for the story to spiral into
multiple directions as the twists and
turns and double and triple crosses keep
piling up the writing and performances
from its returning voice cast are
top-notch throughout with most of the
jokes Landing even if they're not laugh
out loud funny
[Music]
is the fireplace broken or something no
monkey Island's signature brand of
absurdist humor is fully intact whether
it's riffing on past gags touching on
Modern themes with its tongue firmly
planted in its cheek or showcasing a
self-referential wit there's also an
earnestness to the whole experience that
can't help but induce a permanent grin
for as much Nostalgia permeates its
setting characters and music it's also
keenly felt in the game's heartwarming
tone as it takes you on another goofy
pirate Adventure seeing guybrush stroll
out onto melee Island's Lookout Point
with the campfire burning and the
bearded Lookout purveying the island
transported me back to playing the
secret of Monkey Island for the first
time you can visit the scum bar and hear
a sales pitch for the 1990 Adventure
game Loom pass under the massive clock
in the Town Square that remains stuck at
10 pm and chat with the voodoo lady in
front of her bubbling cauldron there
have been a few changes since skybrush
last step foot on the Island's
cobblestone streets with a new younger
generation of pirates in charge and a
couple new Proprietors take taking up
residence but returning players will
feel right at home particularly as the
soundtrack arranged by returning
composers from the series past invokes
familiar Melodies that first burrowed
into ears decades ago
[Music]
newcomers won't have the same immediate
connection but the series has always had
a strong sense of place and return to
Monkey Island is no different whether
it's the jaunty Caribbean inspired music
or the amount of detail etched into
every scene Monkey Island has always had
a distinctive feel much of this has to
do with the game's evocative art style
which has been an unfortunate point of
contention leading up to the game's
release each entry in the series has
always introduced a new art style to
keep things fresh and reintroduce the
world with a visual reimagining and
return to Monkey Island does this with a
blob everything from its characters to
backdrops to items looks like it was
pulled from a colorful storybook with
expressive caricatures and gorgeous
close-ups bringing the world to life
with an eye-catching aesthetic it's a
visual style that looks modern and the
same can be said of its gameplay as well
the old scum-based point-and-click
interface of selecting different verb
commands such as talk to and pickup has
been replaced with a streamlined system
that often gives you one or two context
sensitive options with interacting with
an item or character bringing up your
inventory lets you grab items and pull
them into a scene either to give them to
someone place them somewhere or combine
them with something there's also a handy
to-do list located in your inventory so
you can keep track of your goals it's
all very intuitive and lets you focus on
solving the Myriad puzzles that return
to Monkey Island throws your way at the
beginning of each playthrough you're
given a choice of two difficulty modes
casual which makes puzzles simpler by
removing some of the steps needed to
solve them and hard which features more
and harder puzzles akin to the games of
the 90s whichever option you choose
return to Monkey Island continues the
series tradition of challenging you with
creatively obtrused conundrums to solve
they're rarely completely abstract and
there is a playful logic to most of the
solutions all of the puzzles are
intertwined with the game's storytelling
too with many often triggering a chain
reaction where solving something for one
character will open up solutions for
others figuring out how various items
combined together and then using them to
crack a brain teaser is inherently
satisfying although there are couple
puzzles that disappointingly reuse the
same solution and later on there's some
back and forth travel between numerous
locations that could have been handled
more smoothly if you are struggling to
find out the answer to a specific puzzle
return to Monkey Island introduces a
magical hints book that you can turn to
when completely stumped rather than
pointing you to the correct answer
straight away you can ask this enchanted
book questions to gradually receive
hints that will help nudge you in the
right direction it sounds simple but the
system is rather ingenious the game
knows which puzzles you've already
solved and what items are currently in
your inventory so each question and hint
is tailored to your current
circumstances using the hint system is
also entirely optional letting you
ignore it entirely or lean into it only
when you're truly stuck return to Monkey
Island is a game for the series fans
there's a scrapbook on the main menu
that recounts the events of past games
but it's light on specifics and feels
more like a refresher course than a
vital tool for newcomers to catch up on
previous hijinks returning players will
adore the fan service and familiar sense
of warmth that permeates the whole
experience yet it still strives to make
itself somewhat approachable for
beginners there's no denying that
certain elements will be lost without
that decades-old connection but having a
history with the series isn't essential
to enjoy guybrush threepwood's latest
Escapade return to Monkey Island tells a
wholesome and compelling tale of
swashbuckling shenanigans that should
appeal to anyone seeking a hearty
Adventure on the high seas
[Music]
we gotta get going you say goodbye first
no you say bye first oh you say bye
first
no you say bye first no you say bye
first
[Music]
no you say bye first okay
bye
bye
bye